we were having a huge fight upstairs
with my niece and bobby
about george's appearance we were like
george is a handsome guy and you were
like
in what [ __ ] world yeah i know i
think so he's very happy coming from the
lesbian you have no idea
all right you have no room okay
valid yes george coming from the lesbian
i think you are beautiful yeah and also
europe because he has
these feminine touches of like softness
and kind
you're just kind uh-huh i just find that
you're kind of oh my god
i have a feeling that no matter who was
sitting there
you would had some sort of compliment
right yeah 100 i would like to call it
but that's not real it is no you have to
be real
sometimes you compliment and compliment
and compliment because then you're just
naturally start to think and believe
everything you're saying
okay that's good that's to be positive
person that's true but what i'm saying
is is that
that's not necessarily a f there's when
you look at a human being
there are a variety of facts and things
that are evident
right you're the type of person that
sees the positive stuff
yes like oh my god this person's so ugly
but you know i'm gonna say no
i would never start with in your head
you're not saying that
you don't think you can do it wait wait
but no no i'm going to tell you why
so because ugly is a word that only
should exist
if it's a character-driven trait i agree
that's an ugly
thing right like if you're [ __ ]
racist you're ugly if you're an [ __ ]
you're ugly
if you suck at being kind to people
you're ugly it should never be based off
of physical
right traits i mean look you're the one
who preaches hegemony
is that the word and about how everyone
is
influenced differently about beauty and
i grew up watching sumo wrestling
therefore i find you attractive
like i grew up watching takanohana
akebono
um musashimaru the [ __ ] and they were in
the front
i've never even heard that from you
before because i grew up in asia so like
they
right they were dating super models and
so like my and i watched it with my dad
it was
so it's a very nostalgic thing for me to
see a fat man in diapers
yeah and so when i met you i was like
you are that's akobono
hot and all right so [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you you're saying that that's me
look oh if there's another guy they
called pretty boy
you look a little bit more like him i
think his name is musashimaru
it's like if i i was dating gilbert and
i said you know i like your face because
you know when i was a kid i was looking
at the national geographic there we go
and i saw this
the shelter island statues you know the
heads that are on that right east
east yeah i don't know
the correct shelter island
easter
[Laughter]
get that [ __ ] right all right all right
okay it's oh really now i'm gonna go
back to
that's funny to you look look all i'm
saying is you're not
my idea of hot or what you think is like
aesthetically pleasing is very different
and that very so she's right
ugly comes from the inside you're right
and you know what i
because i grew up at the comedy store
in the night in the 90s yeah right and
that was
the culture the culture was just ripping
each other apart
you know what i mean right however
oh god do you still find joy does that
bring joy to your heart yes
this is good this is gonna be we're
turning this podcast into a therapy
okay okay yeah yeah so that brings you
joy why
what are you trying to protect or what
are you trying to keep at arm's length
by insulting people yes it's i'm not
insult
i'm not insulting please answer
questions you are insulting people
i'm not insulting anybody you're gonna
call him a [ __ ]
i'm not insulting anybody all right it's
it's a sign
of um camaraderie and brotherhood
when you kind of rip you if if people
go like when i'm in new york and i see
like jim norton or whatever right
look at this fat baby walking down the
street and i'm walking down the street
we all laugh about it and we connect
when it comes to that kind of stuff
i enjoy it so does so but so if i were
to give you a laundry list of
compliments
yeah would it make you feel
uncomfortable or it depends because some
of the compliments that you would say
yeah is probably not true or no how
about they are because no
i don't want lies i don't want lies no
they're not lies
can we try it right based on the [ __ ]
that you know about me
yes and i will tell you if it's a lie or
not okay okay first of all
i think one of the greatest qualities
that you have and i think that it goes
for anybody that has overcome
anything that is hard is the sense of
resilience
and sense of awareness and sense of self
now that doesn't mean everything you do
is perfect
but it does mean that you are very self
aware and that you can understand where
you're coming from
and why you choose to make change yes
but that's something that you can say to
virtually
anybody that's not true can i talk
may i it's not getting up getting up on
all right not everybody
it's shelter island by the way i'm
[ __ ] standing by it i like it shelter
island statues
standing by it so my point is is this
okay
that's your head and that's gilbert to
be fair what do you look like
you know what i accept that it's
camaraderie yeah it is camaraderie
and it's fun right i imagine this just
just let me can i talk
all right imagine this what if i didn't
say anything to you at all
he doesn't like me yes i also just want
to add and this is such like a goddammit
this is such a compliment that you have
you do have that head and you do have
christina hendricks hips
oh yeah i've always been jealous of that
girl can you say
he's a big butt he's got the biggest
butt oh my god oh my god
i go that yeah yeah gilbert
yeah yeah juicy butt come on okay i
don't want to talk about gilbert's butt
anymore
or more we can it is juicy but
nonetheless i don't want to talk about
it
i just realized how juicy it was when
you did that yeah
like i would if i was [ __ ] you
from behind yeah i would want you to
push into me with those
[ __ ] bubbles and the whole time
you're like shelter island
shelter so anyway um let me go back to
um hey guys we're gonna take a really
quick break to share some of our
favorite sponsors with you